today's topic we got some more jubilee
for y'all we make assumptions about
people
all the time it's not necessarily a bad
thing but how often are we actually
right about the assumptions we make
and how often are we right about the
assumptions other people make about us
to find out we decided to put someone in
the hot seat and have 100 strangers rate
them one to 100 based on various levels
of first impression
i feel like this would be a great title
for a [ __ ]
we could say that okay
it's a good question i don't know we'll
find out
hi my name is julia and i'm 20. what
would you rate yourself
average to good like kind of in between
seven seven and a half a seventy or
seventy five yeah yeah sure yeah
every girl is going to rate themselves
listen say what you want about kevin
salazar but he had me die we say rate
yourself from one to ten but you can't
use seven
this is why he said that that's why he
said that and i agree they almost always
use seven
or eight that's like the the number
that's why i like it when a girl's like
i'm a nine i'm a nine like yeah say that
if you think you're that hard say it
yeah okay i hate i could disagree
i hate the fake humble oh i could
disagree oh
but yeah say it say what you think
everyone uses seven
this first group of people will only be
able to look at you
um could she show her ears
[Music]
what did you say to me
can she show her here
okay cool
she was like a very pretty girl for me
like
100 like people who could be a like a
model she wasn't really my
type she just looked like a plain
regular type of person
you just said she basic
which is fine okay they all gave her
like 100 like
75 was the lowest and everyone after
that was like 80 and above
you know the problem with this kind of
thing it depends
of of your surroundings and what you're
used to
and what you can get if
to you because when
that guy said oh i gave her a hundred
the guy gave her a hundred i mean
maybe he thinks that she out of her
league and she's like well that's a
hundred
that's in the categories that is out of
my league that is uh
you know what i mean maybe it's because
of his surroundings maybe the people
around him
um no not you it's possible there's a
possibility
it doesn't necessarily mean that it is
actually
you know to the world or whatever
whatnot but yeah okay two things one
if you have people's cameras on then
their face is drawn and people are very
reluctant to be mean to other people
online
so in terms of getting honest feedback
this is not the medium to do it
generally because most of these people
unless you have that black lady from the
cut who just keeps it a buck
the rest of these people are not going
to just say like it is right true
and the second thing is i think people
confuse
two things they confuse what
me as a person find attractive versus
someone being attractive
i personally don't find her attractive
at all she's not my type i would never
want to be
but i can also acknowledge that she's an
attractive person
you're not attracted to her yeah she's
attractive yeah but she just doesn't
attract you kind of meddle exactly it's
like
if i don't eat burgers i won't say
burgers aren't delicious clearly
everyone loves burgers and they
salivate over them just it doesn't suit
my taste buds exactly so those two
things have to be and i think that's a
problem that a lot of people have
they impose their standard of
what it's like they impose their
standard
of like their personal opinion on what
they think a quality product is and
like i know some people who won't like a
genre because it's horror
it doesn't mean that all horror movies
are trash to them they just don't like
that category yeah so i just think that
what you said is like they're pretty
good it was not your rating system it
was
it is an eight but it's not a eight i
like yeah
there's plenty of beautiful women out
there who i don't think are attractive
to me
yeah of course because it's not my type
right i look at models a lot of the time
and just seeing their skinny figures
does not appeal to me
but i can understand that objectively a
lot of people find that attractive
[Music]
well first off julie is giving me
fashion
fun and quirkiness and i'm loving it
she's absolutely stunning
i'm one of the most beautiful people you
could have chosen
she's super pretty and she's also like
not afraid to be yourself
and she also sounds like really funny
like i just listened to a part of one of
her videos
and she was telling like a funny story
and that just made her even more pretty
like i'm gonna cry they're so nice
obviously she's very attractive
but like i see some of her posts where
she's advocating for black lives matter
i'm privileged and i will never
understand what it's like to be black
she's woke so she's hot this is yeah
this is
this is what you would expect from a
jubilee it's social media it's not real
guys it doesn't mean anything she
supports black lives matter and that
made her way more attractive
it's just crazy to me that people inject
like their political
views into viewing someone attract oh my
god you supported trump you're ugly
what what are we talking about everybody
else was saying that she was beautiful
i don't know i didn't really find her
attractive or anything it's not the type
of girl i'd usually like go for
[Applause]
there's people are so nice i was able to
cry they're so sweet
i love how they were like really putting
the importance on not just like the
outside but like on the inside there's
mostly
some kind how it's not real it's not
real
it's not real listen i i find this girl
incredibly annoying but i also
think in her defense as annoying as she
may be
she's also 21. she's got time to grow
i was probably hella annoying when i was
20 as well so
i'm just running out the christmas she's
21. yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah before 25 i give you a
pass
yes i get it a little bit but the thing
that happened is
a little bit what i'm saying it's not
real i'm not talking about her not being
real
right i'm just imagining in general
what you see in social media is not real
i was not a dig at her
i don't know her it'll be crazy for me
to say she's not real
because it's social media and i'm
judging her on social media to say that
she's
i don't know whether she's real or not
that's what i'm saying but the fact
social media is not a real place and
it's really hard to
base yourself on that this one video's
on so you can just stay on camera
okay
[Music]
hey how are you okay oh it's an actual
person
yeah oh yeah i'm a person oh god hi i'm
julia
hi there
[Music]
[Laughter]
hi your character
hi hi julia
what hobbies are you in
what's your sign aries oh fire queen
you see fire queen oh my god i'm
starting to realize
you're oldest nah bro you know what it
is i'm just starting to realize like
jubilee's audience and how they act and
it makes sense why they're so popular
and that's why you're cringe
yeah that's why because i'm seeing their
audience members and i'm like bro
i'm a virgo but i'm a sagittarius moon
um any hobbies
um all i do is study i'm gonna be a
pre-med
student over there i'm part of a dance
i'm gonna sing or a song right you look
so beautiful by the way i love your hair
your dress like your short hair i wish i
pulled it off i cannot but like
girl you could work it oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
oh my god yeah do it oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god you're
here i'm a guy in your mouth
your hair is beautiful oh my god but
your hair is better oh my god look at
your nails
i want to oh my god you saw i was so so
soft skin oh my god
you're a model no but you're you're
you're natural like oh my god
she is very pretty so and you know she
uh asked me about myself like i honestly
think that was a really sweet aspect of
her making me feel very able so
that's also a plus it's not how the
person is
it's how they make you feel
okay all right let me believe gable's
advocate so the point of the video was
to say like oh my god we we rate people
and sometimes we're not accurately doing
on snap judgment
and then you proceed to tell people to
rate her based off of snap
judgments you're not doing the devil's
advocate
okay hold up hold up i'm just trying to
walk through the thought process
so maybe the point of the video is to be
like we view ourselves worse than how
other people view us
maybe okay if not maybe the point of the
video i feel like they failed any way
that you look at it
because at least if they had had the
same people
rate her just by her voice then by her
instagram
then by um pictures and then and then
and then by her
then you could have at least seen the
progression of whether or not they found
her more attractive when they discovered
more layers yeah but
oh okay i'm saying like yeah i don't
understand the point of the video
or what they were trying to get at
especially if you take different people
but yeah is she more attractive when you
see her
on instagram sure why because you're
seeing her pictures when they're all
photoshopped that's why she got a
highest
score there was she as attractive when
she was on the phone
no because you're limiting how you can
perceive someone so
when i watch these videos right because
to be afraid of jubilee there there were
a couple middle grounds i actually
thought were interesting or some
conversations
but i think they dropped the ball so
much with the with the structuring of
the video
or maybe that's exactly what they want
to do because of the audience the
audience like that so they keep on doing
that
they're not pleasing us because we're
not the audience
sure sure i just think there's a good
opportunity there and and i do think
they are
trying to have what i think they're
trying i just think they don't realize
that sometimes they fail they have what
five million subscribers
some people must like it oh
i mean sure some people must like it so
i'm just saying
and as far as julia goes like you know
whether she's a good person not don't
know don't really care
if we're talking about attractiveness if
you want to talk about like no how do
you view her as a person i wish they
would have also defined it do you find
her physically attractive how do you
rate someone
i guess maybe the point of the video is
to say everyone rates people differently
on different criterias
some people rate people based off of the
fact that you make them feel good other
people rate them
based off of physical attractiveness
other people rate them
how annoying they are yeah but
it's interesting here's what i know
about these ratings though and why
they're trash
people say oh i'm rating the people
based off how they made me feel
but then you'll be a super ugly person
people will be like oh my god you got
amazing personality but they won't [ __ ]
you
so that's why these ratings are trash to
me
because they're not real nah it's like
you want to rate someone
and at the same time you're rating
yourself yeah it's like whenever you
rate they rating them
you want to you want to pass as you're a
good person
yeah while giving you a rating because
you know rating is basically judging
someone
and you don't want to look judgmental so
what you do is that you rate the person
but since it's in in this format you
want to not
look like you're a jackass here's the
thing if you wanted to make a whole
commentary about snap judgments and all
this stuff
you should have defined things a little
bit more clear and you also should have
been honest about the fact that when we
make snap judges we do it based off
mostly about what people look like yeah
that's just my thoughts on it um but
maybe you guys have different thoughts
maybe we missed it and we dropped the
ball
uh in the end those were my thoughts on
this video
[Music]
yeah we used to used to have this one
private in the military his name was
private hornsby
you want to know what his job was
refrigerator tech
you should go hi um private hornsby
refrigerator attack 942
i was like is this [ __ ] out of a comic
book he was so
memey you know what hornsby looked like
he looked like gollum if gollum had been
fed well
and
oh man he was he joining the military
bro
i never met so many memes in my life
yeah i agree and this man
that's like i didn't exaggerate his
voice i can't even do how
hi private hornsby refrigerator tech
942. uh i even remember his number
that's his uh serial number that's yeah
everyone gets again that's what's on
your plaque
and he was the only refrigerator i've
ever met in my life it's a specialty
they get paid bonus so
all this not talking this [ __ ] was
making almost double what i mean
refrigerator make all this money
he could he could talk all you want but
he
he wanted this hi
evan how are you today
all right well i'm off to do my rucksack
march
the same age as you he was
three years older than me he went to
community college and that's how he
became a refrigerator tech
i was i was 19. so i had no bed this man
hey
yo that's how you talk bro i i never
forget some of the people i met in the
military
yeah that's a bit it was a bit the same
but we're just younger
and it's just you you you gave a lot of
power to kids
you know what i mean so me personally it
gave me
it gave me a lot of my yeah
assertiveness but it was
you wonder the difference but first off
you have to be a grown adult making
decisions join the military
and two they gather people from all over
the country from environments you've
never been to or cultures you've never
seen
that was summer camp so they amalgamated
everyone into this one area
and then you had to spend 60 days with
them night and day at the summer camp
that was wow summer camp is a while high
you see some new fees and you never
you like what what what what do you want
no bagels
it's bagels bags bagels
cram cheese cream cheese like uh
y'all don't say creams bro the first
time i heard like an east coast action i
was throwing the [ __ ] off
bro it's fake one i love you hate
bretton [ __ ] plays like
i never love you i love them i love them
yeah yeah